and as we just mentioned on Thursday
president Trump will have a very
high-stakes meeting with Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosen Stein the meeting was
announced after Rosen Stein went to the
White House yesterday and that visit led
to a flurry of reports that he was on
his way out right now he still has a job
Paula Reed is here with the story behind
the intense speculation qala good
morning good morning Rosen Stein's
future remains uncertain after reports
that he discussed the possibility of
secretly recording President Trump
now if Rosen Stein has fired or resigns
when he meets with the president it
would have immediate implications for
the special counsels investigation which
resin Stein currently oversees on the
sidelines of the UN General Assembly in
New York President Trump would not say
if he was going to fire his Deputy
Attorney General but earlier in an
interview the president said firing
Rosen Stein was being looked at we will
make a determination but it is certainly
a very sad story when you see it after
FBI director James Comey was fired in
May 2017 Rosenstein appointed former FBI
director robert muller to oversee the
russia investigation a decision the
president has criticized repeatedly the
New York Times reported Friday that
around that time Rosenstein suggested
recording the President and possibly
invoking the 25th amendment to remove
him from office a former justice
official told CBS News he remembered
Rosen Stein making a comment about
recordings but he felt it was sarcastic
Rosenstein flatly denied any suggestion
of outing the president as absolutely
false
how do you not address that on his radio
show the president's personal attorney
Jay Sekulow suggested that of Rosen
Stein resigns or is fired the special
counsel should pause his investigation I
think it's really important that there
be a step back taken here and a review a
firing would also add political turmoil
for the administration ahead of the
midterm elections well I think if he did
something like that it would it would
cause a furor that I don't think we need
right now all this speculation that
President Trump was going to tell
Rosenstein you
fired on Monday was a distraction from
the ongoing judge Cavanaugh controversy
and now that their follow-up meeting is
scheduled for Thursday it will once
again provide a distraction from that
much-anticipated hearing on Cavanaugh's
accuser Paula thanks a busy day in
Washington on Thursday